i do this way too often with this man he
was kind enough to call in after the
passing of norm mcdonald and uh
i love this guy like a brother one of
the sweetest men on the planet just like
bob saget
he's the roast master general here to
call into the show to talk about the
passing of bob he is the great jeffrey
ross how are you jeffrey oh
you know i'm doing as best as possible
my friends doing as fast as possible i
know and i'm on a late night a lot of
crying i bet you know and i that's why i
reached out i i'll be honest with you as
always so many great ideas that that uh
they start with susie my wife you know
sues and she's just like you should
reach out to jeffrey maybe he wants to
talk about him maybe that would be
helpful therapeutic or whatever you
should have him on and that's when i i
texted you i'm like okay
so i didn't want to bother but i just
figured maybe you wanted to talk about
bob and yeah i'll give you the floor
you know thanks homie um
it took a few days for me to even gather
my thoughts because it's like losing a
brother and i never had another brother
and and
he really
he provided this incredible
safety net in my life bob
was an expert on
comedy but also life
and death and taxes
and and and you know if you needed a
doctor you needed a lawyer you called
bob and
and if you needed advice or you needed a
pastrami sandwich after a breakup in the
middle of the night uh he came and he
did that and
to not have him is gonna be
really it's gonna be
awful
it really is
he would he would love the outpouring
he would have loved this
when did you first meet him
jeffrey
you know a little vague because
i i can we always tried to remember and
it was probably passing
in the hallways at the comedy clubs
but
i think it was the aristocrats movie
that really brought us together the
documentary probably made about 15 years
ago
and it had a lot of funny comedians
uh doing the same dirty joke and bob had
the dirtiest version of this old
aristocrats joke
and for whatever reason him and i
were sitting next to each other at the
premiere in new york
and we would just start heckling uh
our friend robin bronk from the creative
coalition and he'd whisper things in my
ear to say that he was too afraid to say
here or i would whisper things in his
ear and start
being this funny little uh
like the two old guys from the muppet
show you know
and the whole movie was dirty so we were
dirty heckling and
and we really came together as as
comedians and uh first and as i got to
know the guy you know it's interesting
he was this global tv star
but he passed away
in a hotel room by himself on the road
like a true comic
um
which you know it sounds sad as you say
it but if you think about it it's
probably how a lot of entertainers
including myself might want to go
he he did a two-hour show standing o
i mean who the hell does a two-hour show
but bob bob loved to talk and when he
had a great crowd and you know these
these pandemic era crowds are just the
best of my career and bob was feeling
that too we talked about it
people were so grateful to have live
entertainment when you take something
away
then you bring it back they really
appreciate it
and he delivered this amazing
performance and then he got his car and
he drove another couple hours
to his next gig for the next day and
he called kelly and he he posted about a
show
and he just died he just died right
there in that bed tucked in with the
lights out
hopefully he didn't suffer too much
um
somebody had to knock this
betty white off the internet
you're too much this no good punk betty
white had to be taken off the internet
the roast master general jeffrey ross
here on the rich eisen show so let's
talk about the saggett roast um some
great moments from that that i've been
going down like a youtube wormhole over
the last few days what was that like
jeffrey
yeah yeah the saggett roast from back in
the day you know i i've been i've been
at bob's house the last couple of nights
um
uh you know with his fan with his wife
and and the full house cast and and john
mayer and uh
and our friend mike binder
and and it's interesting to see
um
all the people that he worked with over
the years and and just being in the
and they're still laughing about you
know all the millions of shows they did
together
and
i was really distraught i was really sad
and i drove home two nights ago about
midnight and my cousin ed was here at my
house waiting on me taking care of my
pup
and he had the bob saget roast
all cued up on a projector in my living
room
so we were
giant life-size
bob saget was sitting on his throne in
my living room when i came home
and it was great
you know um
it was like watching you know the thing
about that roast rich which i know
you'll appreciate
was it wasn't all just like a celebrity
roast it was a comedy roast he had
comedians around him john lovitz and
jeff garland and susie smith and me
and he had his best friend john stamos
as the rose master and i walked in just
as chorus leachman walked on stage and
said i'm not here to roast bob's [ __ ]
i'm here to bump a bunch
the whole crowd went crazy
and uh you know she was sexy and funny
and a lot of the jokes probably wouldn't
fly today
and she said she looked around the day
and she really was the shining star of
the show because it was all comics guild
but god fated me
and and and cloris leachman she smacked
herself in the head and said somebody
hit me in the head so i could see some
stars
and and i remember norm mcdonald um yeah
um and cloris you know norm did that
wonderful set where he did these like
corny corny jokes
and bob is just dying
and you know you look at bob whether he
was a 19 year old on the rodney
dangerfield hbo specials or a 65 year
old running around
the comedy uh circuit
he really kind of looked the same like
i'm aging at rapid speed but somehow bob
who you know loved his uh his uh
martinis and cigars
looked great his entire life like it's
just unimaginable that you wouldn't just
see that guy laughing
that laugh and uh
one of my favorite jokes in that roast
was um
um
at the end of my set you know bob bob
the aristocrats was still kind of riding
high in the in the cultural uh zeitgeist
and bob was really embracing his
dirty daddy persona he was being uh
super hilarious and in his stand up and
he just released a special where he was
pretty raunchy
um
and
i said you know bob if you noticed i
didn't curse once during my show tonight
i didn't want to compete with the master
but
i would like to leave you uh you know in
the honor in honor of the late great
george carlin who just passed away i
said i'd like to leave you all
with another seven words
you'll never hear on television
[Laughter]
we had this running joke rich we had
this running joke uh for years that it
was going to prove me wrong that he was
going to win it evie
and
um you know i always hoped he would
prove me wrong
and all i can hope is that somehow you
know he gets that emmy in the sky
somehow
because he really was
the most wonderful talented
he loved comedians he loved people he
respected people
um you know i saw a lot of my uh female
colleagues talking about how much he
respected women and loved working with
women and
i go to his house and you know jody and
candace and laurie and all the the girls
the twins they all just love him so much
he took this fake tv family and he made
it his real family he did
he did he had a beautiful family on his
own and my wife loved bob saget she is
so brokenhearted right now jeffrey
and because she met him first before
meeting me and
you know and in just his sweetness his
niceness his love of people and making
them laugh
but the thing i want to point out here
you haven't seen we have this photograph
of you and bob
together that we've shown a couple times
and i want to show it one more time it's
in front of the drop and uh the
step and repeat drop behind you and it
has the scleroderma research foundation
symbol on it because that's what he was
really all about too because his sister
died of this awful disease called
scleroderma
and and he would get you and i mean name
it and he he would call people up and
say
i need you i need you here and what can
you give me to auction off you know what
can you give me what can i get what can
what can what can we do to raise money
and you come here and do a set in front
of like you know 400 people in a in a
ballroom
and everyone would come because it was
bob asking you know and he never asked
for anything ever other than that
correct that was the ask and i don't
care if you were robin williams i don't
care if you're you know the biggest star
on the planet he had josh grove and he
had john mayer he had jimmy kimmel you
know he had his buddies like us through
those auctions and i always said like
you didn't really ever know bob until
you saw him host
one of those scleroderma shows right
because that's when it all came out
that's when you saw this vulnerable
mensch with crying in front of his
friends and family about his sister
and
you know
i'm not even superstitious rich but
um bob's daughter aubry was telling me
um you know bob had two sisters who
passed away young
and um both tragically one only one from
scleroderma and one
uh
another way
and interestingly enough
um
um
that bob and one and his sister that
passed away from scleroderma both died
on the same day
which happened to be the first sister's
birthday
the whole thing had this strange cosmic
flip to it in bob's life he experienced
way too much tragedy and somehow his his
daughters
they kind of have this sunny disposition
and they have this sense of humor
uh and they're great laughers and bob
would always bring
his daughters to the comedy store or the
comedy cellar in new york
and they have
that you know they they're they have
that smile and that that that saggitism
uh sense of humor and
and i think he imparted on a lot of us
too like you said i heard you say
earlier how you felt comfortable doing
um
um at midnight standing next to him he
really did help me relax
he was everybody's rabbi yeah
yeah
yeah i felt that i felt that what do you
think he and rickles are doing right now
complaining
why is it me why is it me
bob of all the people that could come up
here that'd be you
i'm not done roasting betty white yet
and now you're here
anyway
anyway anyway it's great right
i love you jeffrey ross i know what
bob's doing he's at the pearly gates
name dropping
[Music]
he's tipping the valet i know that
i love you jeffrey ross we'll chat in
the next couple days brother thanks for
doing it i love your tribute i love you
so much thank you thank you for you know
keeping his memories so just always
always always take care you be well
that's jeffrey ross the roast master
general
he's just the best man
somebody had to knock betty white off
the page
punk betty white
betty white
says jeffrey ross hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here